[Music]
welcome to best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go with
each video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day eight and we're going to learn how
you can develop more self love
[Music]
the truth is
you don't have anything to give
that you don't have
so you have to keep your
own self full
that's your job i say to the my girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out
where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason why you're
here that's that's the number one thing
you have to do
is to work on yourself and to fill your
self up
and keep your cup full keep yourself
full now i used to be afraid of that
i used to be afraid particularly from
people who say oh she said she's still
fella hassan
she's so close herself and now i embrace
it
i i consider it a compliment that i am
full
of myself
because you only when you're full
i'm full i'm overflowing my cup run is
over i have so much i have so much to
offer and so much to give and i am not
afraid of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it
first of all for me my father and mother
never married they had sex one time
underneath an oak tree because she was
wearing a poodle skirt in 1953
and my dad
to this day says i want to know what's
under that skirt that's what i want to
know
he wanted to know what was under the
skirt they didn't really have a
relationship she wanted one but you know
he went under the skirt and that was it
and
one time under the oak tree bam
renaissance woman is born
it happened there
that's why i know my life is bigger than
that my life has to be bigger as yours
is bigger than a moment than a poodle
skirt
it's much bigger the design the the the
reason why i'm here it's much bigger
than oh i think i want to see what's
under there so the ability to to to take
care of that to honor that to honor
yourself and that which is greater than
yourself that which
crea was the reason for your being here
that that that there's no selflessness
in that because only through that
do you have the ability to offer
yourself your whole self your full
expression of who you are to the rest of
the world i mean a thousand dollars a
month 300 pounds just i can't do any of
this stuff yeah these people are better
than me yeah so the first thing is
that's the first big problem right there
first big problem is that you have put a
lot of people above you yeah put no one
above you yeah no one whatever but if if
if you believe in something say that
again say that again because that's
you know but you know but the man the
people that make more money the people
that are better looking the ones that
are on social media and they're so good
at this i put god above me besides that
there's no one better than me got it you
have to become an equal so this i look
at it
if you're playing and i talked about it
at your conference if you're playing
roger federer yeah okay
be before you get on the court with
roger federer he's the best of all time
yeah but you're also a professional
tennis player man
you're forgetting your own resume yep so
once you get on the court let's say it's
a grand slam
it's five sets hopefully if you can go
the distance with this guy yep but
before you even bounce the ball to serve
it
you're down two sets because while you
look across and you're playing roger
federer yeah but guess what you get a
good shot on roger federer in the third
set
and you realize i can play with this
but it's too late yeah you gave up two
sets before you go on the court
you gotta stop giving up two sets before
the game begins and we do that already
we give two sets before the game begins
i remember
i had great angst every night before i
went out because i was not able to be
myself
uh of wrestling
that night 20 000 fans started chanting
rocky sucks
it was a sobering moment and that was
the beginning of the end
of my
initial run in the wwe a few weeks later
um
i tore a tenon into my knee and i was
out for the rest of the summer and i
came to the realization before i went
back that it wasn't me
personally that they didn't like
it was that i wasn't being me
i wasn't being real i wasn't being
authentic who is this guy
in wrestling who's smiling when he's
getting beat
a few weeks later i got a call from the
wwe and i spoke to vince mcmahon he said
when you come back
we could continue to
shove you down people's throats or we
could turn your heel because they want
to boo you anyway
i said i think it's a great idea and i
said uh before we get off the phone i
run requests i said when i come back and
we go live
[Music]
i just need two minutes
live
me talking to the audience live two
minutes is all i'm asking he said okay
you got it a couple of weeks later i
came back we were on live tv
i grabbed the microphone
fans were already booing they started
chanting
sucks the country i heard chants of
in
rocky
rocky sucks
i said um
i may be a lot of things
but sucks isn't one of them
but sucks isn't one of them
in that moment the rock
was born
and
about a month
later
i was the hottest heel in the company
and things were on fire
and the greatest lesson about that is
be you
be
yourself whether it's in entertainment
whether it's
out in public
whether you're celebrity or not
whatever
the most powerful thing you can be is
yourself i've known that one of the most
powerful affirmations you can use is i
love and approve of myself
i love and approve of myself
and when you first say that it's amazing
what can come up and come to the surface
lots of times when we begin to say that
all the negative messages come to the
surface
and it's marvelous because that gives us
an opportunity to know what's been in
the way you see if you don't hear your
negative messages you don't know what's
in your way so when you start to do an
affirmation like i love and approve of
myself you want to really pay attention
to what the negative messages are
because they're the ones that are in the
way and when you find a negative message
if you could write it down it's
wonderful because you want to think i
found a treasure this is something
that's really in my way and really
creating a problem
remember we get to choose the way we
think and we can choose to change the
way we think
it's always our choice
now what i'd like you to do right now is
take out those little mirrors that you
have i know everybody has a little
mirror
okay
good now let's see if you can look in
your eyes without primping
see if you can manage to do that
i want you to look in your eyes
and i want you to say
i love you
i love and approve of you exactly as you
are
[Music]
okay now just begin to notice
what you're feeling
don't judge it just notice what are the
feelings that are coming up
are they feelings of joy
do you feel you feel wonderful about
yourself
are they feelings of criticism or
negativity don't judge them just notice
what's coming up acknowledge the
negative message
just acknowledge it and you can always
say thank you for sharing
and realize that the the negative
messages that are coming up now are very
much the things that are in the way of
you loving yourself okay what i want to
do right now is let's do it just a
little bit of sharing
okay i want to know what sort of
messages are coming up from you
yes
fear who would be upset if you really
loved yourself
me
no no no no no no no it always goes back
farther who would be upset if you really
loved yourself
my parents your parents which one both
of them yeah
um
always judgmental always um
okay so you came from a critical
judgmental resentful family right okay
fine so you're wonderful and fearful oh
boy you really got it all right
okay it just means that you have a
little more to work on you know i really
think that some of us are very young
souls and we come here and it's like
going to kindergarten life is really
very simple and some of us are much
older souls and we pick tougher tests
and it's more like going to graduate
school
but you know you can do it
it's just that you've chosen perhaps a
little more difficult things to overcome
but see it's my belief that the main
thing that we really come here to work
on is loving ourselves in spite of what
they say and in spite of what they do
and that's what we really need to do so
okay you've got things you've got credit
you've got judgment you've got criticism
you've got fear probably a little guilt
in there too
okay then you you
i i like to always think of that we can
go beyond our parents limitations you
know they had a limited way of looking
at life and you were a very good little
child so you learned what they taught
you
see a lot of us think that we're bad and
we're not good enough and we're no good
but actually we're ideal wonderful
loving little children and we learn
exactly what our parents teach us
not always what they tell us to do but
we learn from them
and we learn exactly what they do and we
grow up doing the same thing the world
doesn't need another perfect person
the world needs you
and you're trying your best
you're doing what you can
and you know i think it's really
important that you cut yourself a break
and that you stop thinking that you have
to be perfect there are going to be days
where you're an hour late to pick up
your kid and that's okay
there are going to be days when you
can't get to every email and that's okay
there are going to be days where you
feel so underwater and that's okay
you'll get through it you'll figure it
out and you've got to understand that
it's not about being perfect
it's about just being you and that means
that you got to be willing to start
before you're ready you got to be
willing to
do what i do every damn day which is
show up in my rollers or start a live
stream and disconnect myself or start it
and be talking and not even know that
i'm broadcasting
you've got to do that version in your
life or you're not going to get ahead
period you already know the thing about
love yourself and maybe in some ways
you've never allowed that
you've never noticed the beautiful
things you've done in your life
so you've never allowed yourself to love
yourself
but at some point
you've got to recognize that there's a
love that's beyond you
and beyond me and beyond your actions
and that love is whatever bought us here
alive today some would say it's god's
will and god's love some people it's the
randomness of the universe some people
it's nature some people it's whatever
but there is something way beyond us
and there's a way to access that and a
way to honor that and the way to honor
that is to recognize that you are unique
about of seven billion people no one is
like you specifically
and
at least take that as a moment saying
okay
i'm meant to live my uniqueness
i'm out i'm supposed to love the things
that make me odd and weird i'm supposed
to love the things that make me strong
i'm supposed to i was made this way so
let me honor what's good about that and
what's not good about that let me work
on that let me set a schedule to get
better at that so that i can not only
honor what i've been given but i can
give something back to by getting better
and that aspect of doing that that
brings in so much joy and so much
strength in our life is love loving
ourselves loving the process and of
course the greatest way to believe in
ourselves is to love other people that
they become so grateful for us
that they give us some of that feedback
that they that there's so much
appreciation and love and joy in the
moment with others that you can't help
but just feel that vibe that there's an
emotional contagion when other people
around you are feeling loved and cared
for and excited about life it's hard not
to rub off on you a little bit and you
start to say you know what life isn't so
bad and you know what i deserve to feel
good here right now too and you know
what you start getting some momentums
some wins you integrate those wins you
get some feedback to get better and all
of a sudden you start to believe in
yourself again all of a sudden you start
to live
the charge
i love me
so with the day that you decide to stop
loving me
i'm not gonna love myself any less
i believe in me
if you stop believing in me
i'm not gonna believe in myself any less
if you believe that i'm irrelevant
that no one is checking for me
and that i don't mean anything to the
world because you think or believe that
about me it doesn't believe it doesn't
mean that i'm gonna believe it about
myself
see
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion
is the beginning of the end most of
y'all
and it's [ __ ] up i see it every day
all day
most of you guys
don't actually know your self-worth
you don't know yourself value
so you're like a vulnerable little child
and you're you're shaking
and it's like everybody loves me this
week so i love me this week
next week
it drops
so now you're running around insecure
feeling self-conscious
and not loving yourself sad and
depressed
based on the feedback the responses and
the energy that the rest of the world is
giving you
i wrote about this in my new book which
is coming it's called black rose
it hasn't been released yet but it's
coming i talk about the fact that fame
is an addiction
fame is one of the most unspoken
addictions out there
so many celebrities and entertainers
athletes and public figures
they base their self-worth
on their relevancy
based on everybody in the world checking
for and as soon as people stop checking
for them then they stop checking for
their self
y'all don't love me no more i'm not
selling records i'm not number one in
the box office no more i'm not making as
much money as i used to make
oh sh ain't nobody checking for me so
guess what i'm not checking for myself
no one sees the value in me anymore
so i don't see the value in me anymore
every time i go on twitter facebook they
say i'm irrelevant
so i'm irrelevant to myself now
i ain't
because you think
that i ain't
no one loves me because you said no one
loves me i don't love me
the day that you allow the opinions of
the outside world
to dictate the way you feel about
yourself
it is the beginning of the end of you
living a blessed and self-loving secure
life
i can tell y'all right now
that it is not the car that i drive or
any of the jury that i own or the size
of my house that defines my self-worth
i'm hot
i'm hot
i'm hot when you don't think i'm hot i'm
amazing when you don't think i'm amazing
i love me even if you stop loving me you
can say the nastiest meanest evil issue
that you could ever conjure up it will
never change the way i feel about myself
i'm telling you
that's the way i live my life that's how
i feel about me most of y'all are on
twitter
you're desperate for likes
you're desperate for the the the
egotistical feeding frenzy feed my ego
feed feed feed like me like me
because i don't like me
i'm telling y'all right now
the day that you
allow the opinions of everybody on the
outside world to define your day-to-day
month-to-month and year to year it's the
beginning of the end love yourself
believe in yourself
love yourself believe in yourself
independent of the validation of the
world
have opinions and feelings about
yourself independent of the feedback
why you got to have somebody calling you
beautiful every day in order for you to
feel beautiful
do you believe that you're beautiful or
do you only believe you're beautiful
when other people say that you're
beautiful
i'm just asking
self-love is the cure to self-hate
if you make it to the end of this video
i want you to write self-love is the
cure to self-hate
these are the type of qualities that i'm
going and have been in stealing in my
daughter
there is no man that you could ever meet
shayla
that can make you feel more amazing than
what you're supposed to feel about
yourself nobody wants to be alone but if
you show up empty as an empty shell
and you're expecting this man to fulfill
you and fill you up with all the love
that doesn't exist you're gonna be
[ __ ] up
because as soon as he leaves you
depleted you're empty and you have
nothing left for yourself again
never rely or depend on anybody to
fulfill your heart and if you don't
believe in the lord jesus christ you
better get to know him
because that's also a part of the
process of self-love
you are supposed to love yourself
independent of any feedback comments
likes
shares and any of all of these other
social media some of y'all are social
media [ __ ]
what does that mean i i i i i i ain't
until people on my timeline tell me that
i'm the [ __ ]
i love me independent of anything that
anybody could ever say has nothing to do
with being arrogant or egotistical it's
just a matter of knowing and being aware
of self-worth
i love you
if you make it to the end of this video
i want you to write self-love is the
cure to self-hate
self-love is the cure to self-hate
and i hope you share this video because
i want this video to spread all over the
world
send it to world star hip-hop
send it to all of the blogs and the
websites
self-love is the cure to self-hate
shaman tyrese spreading love always
share share share click that share
button spread love love circle i love
you always you deserve to be loved even
if you
need to do something for yourself
because real love
doesn't have conditions
real love takes joy when someone is
happy whatever it takes even if it means
being apart from you for a period of
time or even forever
otherwise it's not love
it's the selfish desire to get what you
want whether it makes someone else happy
or not
some of you are in relationships where
you're committed to the ship and not the
relations
you're committed to the institution and
you forgot the person
because you don't even meet the person
anymore you meet your story about the
person because you've told it to
yourself so many times so everything is
seen through that filter
if you think someone is your dear dear
friend and
they're loving and they're generous and
they're a beautiful soul and one day
they treat you like
you'll be shocked and you'll be angry
and if you can't resolve it
and you have to leave to go deal with
something you'll generalize their
behavior later on you'll say they're
probably having a bad
what
how many of you had a day will you hope
somebody generalized your behavior is
just a bad day
but if somebody you think that they
don't care
or they're selfish or they're mean
because you've generalized about the
human being
because by the way you can find
selfishness in anybody if you look for
it including yourself
whatever you look for you're going to
find you can you find beauty can you
find love can you find generosity in any
human being yes or no i love being
self-aware i suck at a lot of things
i just don't think about them like i
can't read for sh
i interrupt people when i interview them
24 7. everybody's super pissed on the
internet about that not good because i
already know what the person's saying i
can't help it i'm sorry there's plenty
of things that i'm not good at i love
self-awareness i like it's kept me so
happy
like
you know i'm not upset of myself that
i'm selfish in certain areas
that's human i think that we just don't
love each other
ourselves enough
i i think we
i don't know whose
perfection i'm trying to live up to
like if i like silly things like people
get on me for biting my nails
gives a [ __ ]
like people just critiquing themselves
all day long my dreams are first every
day then my wife then my kids
i can take care of my wife and my kids
now would you agree i abandoned this
this is the fuel for who i am i abandon
this dream
and then i end up i can't take care of
them
and then i'm gonna tell them what
it's all right that you didn't win
no it's not all right if you don't win
you need to win how many of you need to
win more
okay
if you don't control your environment
folks somebody else is going to control
your environment you guys that run teams
and run organizations if you do not
control your environment someone else
will control your environment you are
being controlled in your environment
right now cnbc cnn msnbc the parents the
kids the twitter the facebook the
youtube the google the snapchats
are your environment your friends and
your relatives your uncles your aunts
the garbage dump called planet earth
that you live on is mostly broken people
you don't control your environment it
starts with me
when i was 45 years old i'm like i'm
going to control my environment i'm
going to take every penny i have all the
energy i have all the resources i have
and i'm going to improve me if i got to
go broke in the process because i'm
already broke look if you're not
fulfilled to your if you're not reaching
your full potential every day you're
broke right now we've been taught
how to serve others
sometimes
to the detriment of our own selves
sometimes we serve others
higher than we serve ourselves
at times we feel more comfortable
with saying yes to other people
and less comfortable
saying yes to our own self-care
so i ask you
what is that about
it's about the opportunity to fall madly
in love with you
the way you love those around you to
fall madly in love with your well-being
to fall madly in love with who you are
when you get up from taking care of
yourself you when you rise from a nap or
you rise from um uh a spa day or when
you leave the gym to fall madly in love
with that level of excellence
and when you do
what you'll do is give to everyone else
around you a better version of you
so often times we sacrifice our own
well-being because we're being what i
call the sacrificial martyr and i know
that was me i would serve everybody else
and everyone else would go oh i just
don't have any time for lisa
well
that's the story we tell
i actually
didn't believe that i deserve
to have a day off
i didn't believe that i deserved to have
a spa day i didn't believe that i
deserved to
take a long walk on the beach
something in me kept saying that i
hadn't done enough
i hadn't achieved enough
i hadn't gotten far enough
so it actually had little to do with the
people around me that i was blaming it
on or using as my out
my child my parents my family my
community
it had to do with lisa
giving lisa the chance
to actually enjoy the journey
while still on it i listen to my own
self
sally coming to the office i'll be
crying
god damn i love this
how good can i be god jesus christ i
can't get much better god
allah
i love listening to myself talk
i adore
i i really adore myself
you can't love anybody unless you love
yourself first
and that's self-esteem
self-confidence
um some people even
say it translates over into
self-awareness i don't know about that
that's a little airy fairy for me
self-awareness
but nobody where i grew up talked about
self-confidence
a lot of the kids a lot of the
street gang guy they have
self-confidence and they and they really
don't have that much self-esteem that's
why they join gangs but they have
self-confidence to go and fight people
and you know you know
pissing your face not literally pissing
your face but i mean pissing your face
and
the um the current generation
um
actually about a generation and a half
just doesn't most of us i believe don't
love ourselves enough now i don't mean
arrogance self-arrogance i'm talking
about self love because growing up we
don't get enough love from other people
for most of us
for most of us
there's a guy that used to know who had
experienced multiple breakups and to a
point where now he doesn't he doesn't
trust relationships anymore doesn't
trust woman anymore because he doesn't
want to get hurt and i believe her
people hurt people
and you can see on his face when i look
at him he doesn't smile there's no joy
there's no life
right
think about it if you have given a
choice if you could have a million
dollars
for the rest of your life you have a
million dollars but in exchange you
could no longer have intimacy you can no
longer have relationship with anybody
else you can no longer love
in exchange a million dollars would you
take it comment below
you wouldn't because life without love
means very very little and how could you
give love you cannot give something that
you don't have so how could you give
love if
you don't have love yourself how can
love others if you don't love yourself i
realized
i'd say two years ago
but especially in the last six months
very recent
that
and this is the part that would make my
tim of five years ago just cram like
vomit a little in his own mouth which is
uh
i'm not gonna mince words i still have
trouble saying it's like self-love is
not an indulgence it's not a nice to
have
it is a prerequisite
even if all you want to do
is feel successful
and take care of the people you love the
most to really take care of them you
have to
as i've heard said put on your oxygen
mask first
and if you don't do that like you
you are also
shortchanging your ability to care for
other people completely
and
that that's been a very
uh
very much and 180 degree about face for
me
right because for for a long time i was
like i don't need to care for myself
like that's
uh
the word keeps coming back to me which
is self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent like who cares i have a
very important lesson that's something
i've been applying in my own life and a
girlfriend of mine called me yesterday
and she said that she was feeling really
attacked and judged by someone at work
and my response was don't defend
yourself don't fight back don't judge
back your work i said to her is to
the moment that you feel judged and
attacked
do something immediately
to make somebody else feel loved so when
you feel as though someone has attacked
you judged you bullied you doing
anything to make you feel inadequate or
unlovable
do the opposite do the exact opposite go
and do something to make other people
feel good so go make somebody feel
lovable adequate and good enough and
that
simple practice of just
taking yourself out of the knee-jerk
reaction to to fight back or defend but
instead to go give love that can change
everything for you when you feel judged
immediately go give love go do something
kind do something compassionate do
something loving that will be the
quickest way to stop the momentum of the
negative energy there are way too many
haters out there there's so much
negativity there's so much bullying and
there's so much attack and judgment and
that's why i wrote an entire book about
this topic so my hope for you is that
when you feel judged or attacked instead
of attacking back you go give love you
do something to make somebody feel good
you do something that's based in
compassion and love and joy you make
somebody you make someone feel good
about themselves so i was thinking about
um
love
i was thinking about how difficult it is
for us to find and to
to maintain
the love that we all yearn for
and it it kind of dawned on me that i
think a big part of the problem is that
we misdefine love
[Music]
it's possible that no other one subject
has been more analyzed talked about and
experienced by every single person on
this planet than love and yet
we really have
no clue what it is
so me and jada was reflecting
about
love
you cannot
make a person happy you can make a
person smile you can make a person feel
good you can make a person laugh but
whether or not a person is happy is
deeply and totally and utterly out of
your control the thing that we call love
the thing that we're searching for and
we're trying to create that we call love
is actually not love
j krishnamurti talked about the the
concept of the desire
pleasure paradigm that we think about
love in terms of desire and pleasure
meaning that if you meet my needs
then i love you
if you don't
then i don't
so that love becomes transactional if
you do what i want if you meet my desire
and give me pleasure i love you if you
don't meet my desire and you don't give
me pleasure i don't love you i think
that that in the insatiable nature of
desire
trying to get somebody to fill our cup
i think that that leads to to anger and
it leads to
frustration and ultimately it makes us
break apart from people my daughter
willow
really taught me a hard lesson i think
that the real paradigm for love is
gardener flower
so the relationship that a gardener has
with a flower is the the gardener
wants to flower to be what the flower is
designed to be
not what the gardener wants the flower
to be
you want the flower to bloom and to
blossom and to become what it wants to
be you want it to become what god
designed it to be you're not demanding
that it become what you need it to be
for your ego anything other than all of
your gifts wide open giving and
nourishing this flower into their
greatness is not love
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best life 30 questions
of the day now it's not enough to just
watch a video you have to do something
take action so pull out your worksheets
and let's get to work and if you don't
have the worksheets for this video check
the link in the description to get them
for free question number one where do
you need to put yourself first more
number two how can you build honoring
yourself into your daily routine and
number three what would you tell
yourself if you were your own best
friend and if you're doing the best life
30 challenge with me give me a hashtag
bestlife30 in the comments below so we
could celebrate with you
you need to be your biggest critic as
well as your biggest fan
people are usually their biggest critics
you point out all the flaws you tell
yourself all the reasons why you suck
i actually think that's a good thing
being your biggest critic forces you to
get better but it's only healthy if it's
paired with you also being your biggest
fan you think that you suck but you also
feel like you're amazing like you're a
gift to the world like you're the best
thing ever you suck and you're amazing
you're the worst and you're the best
both i think that's the healthy balance
you have to be your biggest critic as
well as your biggest fan both at the
same time if you want to join the best
life 30 challenge click the link right
here below me or if you want even more
videos on how to boost your self love
check out the playlist right there next
to me continue to believe and i'll see
you soon